you're playing with and against all the
different people in the club and you
learn to appreciate them because of that
it's just a little family it's an odd
little sport and it's unique
it's easy to play but hard to master
cafe is the only place where there's
authentic belgian feather bowling in the
united states
it's a bowling game
that
uses
wooden discs
that you throw at a feather at the
opposite end of the length try and get
close to the feather it's similar to
bocce or horseshoes and it's a target
sport that way
the unique thing about this one is that
the lane is convex and
the ball tends to move in odd directions
you can score points by being the
closest with your color ball
closest to the feather of the same color
yellow touching
not touching on yellow some people are
really good right away
other people
they've been a club for a while and i
still don't know what they're going to
do out there when they throw the ball
oh
it was a point and then it wasn't it's
down to one this one kendrick cafe today
is is a bar and a restaurant in detroit
this neighborhood was was a largely
belgian american
neighborhood at one point
when the club started in 1933
this was a place for recent immigrants
after the war to come over and have a
little taste of home more popular that
it's been i mean our average attendance
for bowling every week has gone up that
last three four years
and there's a good group of guys here
you know they're from all
walks of life
you sit there every week with them you
bowl with them you ball against them
and it's just a good time